I usually just start bragging about what
a big star I am and that really is very
like I've never heard of you why do you
keep saying you the volleyball had a
bigger part than you in castaway well
that's probably true so glad to have
this next guest on with us you've seen
him I mean you've seen him in a ton of
films the TV show justified which I know
a lot of you out there love and he's
actually directing the new film Gosnell
movie you can check out more Gosnell
movie com
I have why am i introducing Nick
seriously thanks for being on the show
thanks for having me Steve in that Canon
I can't imagine how excited you must be
okay
well you're right you can't imagine it
so what we're glad to have you on I mean
listen so we did the introduction now
that the formalities are out of the way
I'm trying to think of where we met
initially would it have been through
through Breitbart somehow it's one of
those things where you just sort of yeah
I think so yeah I think it was through
Andrew yeah we were probably at some
gathering or rather and I had seen some
crazy video you're done or something and
then I came up and said hello I remember
I remember introducing myself to you you
did you introduced yourself to me I
think so yeah I mean you were very
disrespectful I remember well yeah that
goes without saying I think I remembered
actually that was the function and the
secret meeting where if like Clint
Eastwood was there remember yes and I
don't have ever told you like there's a
certain level I'm pretty comfortable
around me but you know there are a lot
of celebrities working in entertainment
history is imperiled with them but
there's a certain level of celebrity
with which I don't know how to interact
and I remember Clint Eastwood literally
turned around and he was right there and
I just said hi I'm Stephen and he said
huh I'm Clint
okay just shook his hand and left and
everywhere my friend was playing on his
phone and when Clint was walking out I
remember this collision stealthor he
said so did you rescue the princess
my Clint Eastwood story but the funny
thing is I was actually at a function
this week one of those secret functions
and and I had to do an introduction
onstage I was introducing that speaker
and when I got there they put me at the
table and right beside me was Clint
Eastwood and I just froze I didn't even
I didn't even know what to say I was
like hi mr. Eastwood I'm Nick Searcy you
know and that was it and when I was so
preoccupied with like thinking about oh
no I should have made a better speech
because these jokes are terrible and I'm
gonna bomb in front of cliff changes the
level of pressure I mean it's what do
you say to him when you have that body
of work like hey I loved you in every
which way but loose Clyde was no joke
there's I even like I got a kick out of
every which way you can I'm not even
gonna lie the funniest part of that film
is where clay stood for those of you
haven't seen it he knocks a man out with
a bass the fish just just completely any
way we can get into it he beats the crap
out of women and all those Dirty Harry
films a lot of people just skim over
those alright well that was that was the
peak for Clint I think I mean you know
as in just in terms of acting is that
period but you know now he's he's
surpassed all of that yeah it's like you
can't say anything
wellis right and he's outwardly
conservative so people know that and
people know if they follow you on
twitter is it
real Nick Searcy on Twitter no it's yes
Nick sir yes Nick Searcy okay even more
presumptuous yes it is it is I so you're
out of the closet as a conservative so
I'm not you know I don't want to ruin
any careers here but well you're doing
pretty well well it's interesting you
say that because people do talk right
about the blacklisting and I know coming
up you know before I had my own platform
that I had I had experienced it but I do
tend to believe that sometimes people
blow their victimization out of
proportion sometimes the more ice the
more time I spend around conservatives
in Hollywood
I don't see that as the case have you
felt that push back a lot because you're
so vocal well you know I wouldn't know
it Stephen I mean you know I don't feel
it from you know my agents or my
managers or anybody like that I don't I
don't I don't hear it from them I don't
know what people are saying to me saying
about me behind closed doors if you
don't get a role they don't call you up
and tell you why so right I don't know
it could be happening but frankly I
don't care because I'm old and you know
I'm fine you're not old you're a
character actor but what I'm saying is
I'm kind of like reach the point where
you know I can work with the people that
I want to work with and I don't have to
work with people who don't want to work
with me anyway so that's fine it's it's
what it's what John Berman called in The
Gambler the remake the screw you
position I'm obviously paraphrasing here
because of the AC but exactly I'm kind
of you know I'm kind of their kind of
their yeah well I mean justified what is
it six it was at 60s and seven six
season yeah and that was I mean what a
great experience and and you know that's
the longest series I've ever had you
know which is great at my age
ya know I can imagine and I mean let's
just be honest it's not not that we're
but at six seasons know where the show
obviously it puts you in a pretty good
position not only professionally
financially where a lot of actors don't
really have that luxury and people know
you when they see you and justified so
let me ask you about that so you're on
the set of justified do you ever get
into it with any of your co-stars and
just I mean do you ever get into it as
aggressively as you do on twitter with
the hollywood lives on that set ever
happen you know a couple of times it
happened early on like in the pilot i
got into it with not in a terrible mean
way but you know so i won't say who it
was but one of the one of the stars said
something about it was back when david
letterman made a joke about Sarah
Palin's daughter getting in a room sex
with a
something and you know and they kind of
pooh-poohed that and I said wait you got
a daughter right you know think it'd be
alright if David Letterman made a sex
joke about your daughter and so we kind
of chewed on that for a few minutes and
after that they all went okay don't talk
politics with Nick he's crazy right he's
old I can't be held accountable I'm just
gonna steal stuff but you know what
happened you know is it basically by the
end of the show everybody kind of knew
you know what where I stood and they
actually wrote it into the show I mean
right season five they had or hold on we
have to go to break I want to talk about
that when we get back Nick Searcy a lot
orth Crowder back with the one and only
Nick Searcy yes Nick Searcy on Twitter
and Nick before we left you were going
to tell us a story so you were in this
show justified and obviously I don't
want to typecast you here but that's
just a show that so many people love and
you said that I mean they wrote it into
the show right way it was season five
mm-hmm yeah well what happened was in
season four you know there was this
moment where Rush Limbaugh sort of
mentioned the show mentioned justified
on the air and he mentioned me by name
he said you know it's glad to see art
mowing back Nick Searcy plays for art
he's one of my favorite characters so I
wound up you know through a series of
like my friends tweeting me going oh my
god Russell Limbaugh said your name and
then I tweeted David Limbaugh and he you
know basically I went on the show the
next day and Lang Limbaugh interviewed
me for about 12 minutes you know which
was longer than the interviewed Dick
Cheney by the way Cheney just hung up
what do you want click but anyway that
that kind of aired and then a couple
weeks later one of the writers saw me he
said you know we we listen to your Rush
Limbaugh interview in the writers room I
said oh really
what'd you guys think well we talked
about it and we uh we think you should
do it again if you can yeah because I'm
bringing in all that audience that you
guys have been driving away for a year
right but then in season five they wrote
a scene where my character is sitting in
a truck on a stakeout and he's listening
to Limbaugh on the radio precious
and then you know I think it's the first
time in television history that the
characters actually listened to Limbaugh
during a show and then not immediately
gone and strangled a puppy or like rape
somebody or done something awful right
it's just sort of like a normal guy
listening to the radio writing it yeah
because after all the people who listen
to Rush Limbaugh the 20 million must be
20 million neo-nazis of course do you
think that was so right what drove their
do you think it was just economics where
they go hey this is a big audience and
we don't need to alienate them or do you
think it was just kind of a throwaway
they thought it was cool I mean what's
their motivation because we know they
lean to the left
well you know I think it was I think
really their motivation was accuracy I
mean they've spent a lot of time in
Kentucky they've talked to a lot of the
marshals they you know they and and you
know I mean let's face it it's like
there's prop let's just say there's a
higher percentage of conservatives among
US Marshals and there are among
Hollywood liberals in a Hollywood movie
business so I think they were just sort
of being accurate and it seemed right to
them that you know a person like art
Mullen would probably listen to Rush
Limbaugh that's a good point very fair
point that actually funnily enough is is
sure to not anger anyone we need to get
you your Twitter persona out here just
to make sure that you're throwing down
well okay so justified obviously I mean
you have such a body of work so let's
talk about what you're doing now you
know we just had an McIlhenny on the
show last week okay and or two weeks ago
she was talking about the fracking thing
and the Ferguson play in particular but
Gosnell movie you know broke all the
records for indiegogo over 2 million
raised and then Clavin was named
director Andrew Clavin in writer and you
are director so how did how did that
happen and I mean there's a big
difference between right just discussing
a Letterman joke on set and doing
something this bold what's the reaction
been like well how it happened was you
know and in Salem and I been France and
I started was involved in the
fundraising campaign a little bit and
they asked me to recommend some
directors and so I reckon
a couple people and they met with them
and you know for whatever reason they
were too busy or you know they didn't
want to do a movie this grim and yeah
you know they came back and said you
know anybody else and I said well you
know I directed a movie a few years ago
would you like to see you you know
showed them a movie I directed almost 20
years ago and they you know they watched
it we had a couple meetings after that
and they decided to go with me I sort of
felt like after talking to them that I
really could direct this movie and so I
kind of the more I thought about it the
more I felt like it was calling me so
right it's funny when you say talk with
them we'll get back to the grim subject
matter in a second but when you say
talking with them it usually means
talking with an because I love feeling
but on the phone I can never understand
a word he says in the phone
well they both have accents right but
when you talk to them on the photos
mumbling it there's kind of like sir
like the movie snatch and then but and
even though she has the accent she had
no treats it perfectly because she's
very clear about it so I'm like okay and
I can understand you on the phone for
limb I love you but I have to speak with
you in person so I can read lips
fred's after that um now you do talk
about this right the grim subject matter
I mean people talk about actors you know
going into method act endless and
sometimes it's it's a little overblown
but you do definitely in a way submerse
yourself into the project you're working
on right you're talking about 22 hour
days a lot of people don't realize the
amount of work that goes into a film
have you had to guard yourself or do you
find yourself getting into a depressive
state and dealing with Gosnell because I
can't think of anything darker yeah I
mean especially at the beginning I mean
you know in the opening when we started
really working on the script and turning
it into a shooting script and really
visualizing it yeah it's very difficult
because it's a movie that you have it's
also a movie that you can't see
everything that you're talking about
because people just wouldn't be able to
take it right so you you kind of have
find a way to tell the story without it
being a festival Gore or some sort of
exploitative looking you know horror
film you know and so we managed to make
it I think into a really compelling
crime drama and a courtroom drama which
is more about the you know the detecting
him and and arresting him and convicting
him and it's it's not so much about I
mean that of course the darkness of what
he did is part of the story but it's not
the main part of the story let's say of
course for those listening or seeing
this right now I'm Kermit Gosnell of
course the famous abortion doctor who I
mean really is there's no other way to
put it a mass murderer by anybody's
standards so that's gotta be tough to do
and like I said I mean sometimes people
and I know I mean you don't you teach
don't you have acting classes no I have
a public service acting school which is
just a baby
it's just video classes which I offer
free of charge is a public service to
America with Nick Searcy this is true
this is one thing okay what we're
talking about guys now let's get off
because it gets too serious but one
thing that when people they can be so
self aggrandizing I mean we talk about
wanting to be accurate right and that's
true but then one you have actors and
I've had friends like this for going you
know I'm playing a cop so I went on a
ride-along I'm going you think that you
know what it's like to be a cop because
you wouldn't a ride-along not in Detroit
in Grosse Pointe like there is a level
of self-importance don't you think that
comes with with even though it's hard
work actors sometimes who make it seem a
little bigger than it needs to be yes
absolutely Steven but you know I mean
that's true of a lot of actors not of me
networks no I'm not I'm not a
self-aggrandizing I bet and I have every
right to be you know and I'm just I
don't know
wow there's nothing you could say that
would be self-aggrandizing short of
calling yourself a demigod that's true
it's not bragging if it happens to be
true this is well like an example right
I got into an argument when they Heath
Ledger thing the Joker came up so first
let me preface this probably one of the
best performances ever
in cinematic history I went in ready to
hate it because I thought there's no way
he's gonna top Jack Nicholson you know
he's a hipster blah blah blah like this
is just a bunch of hype and I left
saying wow that's amazing
but what bother me is when it came out
the story right of how he passed away
which is tragic even more tragic and he
left children behind it was just it was
just the role consumed him he was the
Joker for you know nine months after
that I'm going really because I've been
in enough film sets in my life you
believe that when they yelled cut he was
going to the craft services table one
can I have a ham sandwich I mean it
doesn't happen that way right I do think
that is overblown I think and every
actor is different I mean some actors
live in that role you know cuz they they
feel like they have to and some are you
know like me we're not just ago thank
good enough okay the checks still six
figures right we haven't lost my address
that we good well don't say it out loud
because I'm sure they're people who
would love that address right now and
send you some send you some white powder
in the mail get actual like physical fan
mail yeah yeah I do you know so I get I
get you know people send me it's pretty
harmless you know people send me
pictures to sign usually with the
self-addressed stamped envelope and you
know as long as the letter that they
write me is grammatically correct I
usually fulfill the request you ever get
anything I mean I've never gotten
physical mail because I keep everything
under wraps have you ever gotten
something a little weird I mean because
that would picture somebody who sending
an email anyone can do but someone who
takes the time to you know lick the
envelope or you know stamp it with an
old rubber seal screw loose I've gotten
some prank calls you know I've gotten
some anonymous like envelopes with like
you know I hate you why don't you shut
your mouth you know old man I hope you
die soon you know even actually these
are actually there at one point in
history that would be shocking
compared to the youtube comment section
that's incredibly friendly you old man
it's a lot it's a lot milder than jus
[ __ ] which I guess we literally the last
interview we did and I don't know if
we're going to have to bleep this where
it's indicated rest really we talked in
the interview it was with Andrew W K we
talked about people calling me a Jew [ __ ]
even though I'm not Jewish or gay and
then literally like eight comments down
someone who clearly didn't watch the
video you and Jay a couple of two facts
you know but I always just tell them hey
good look in the seventh grade right hey
what are you gonna do yeah I mean well
you're a pretty bright guy and obviously
you know conservatism lends itself to
that and you play it up like I just got
corrected today we're we were talking
about that you know Lord of the Flies
conch shells like its conch shell I mean
how do you handle because you get so
much of that and I'm sure it's even
worse in person on set as a smart guy do
you just have to brush it off or do you
actually take time to correct everybody
you know I don't get it much on set
people people don't come after me in
person you know they don't have the
balls you know but I'm Twitter I just
try to to you know have fun with it and
just like you know make fun of people
that are attacking me yeah I mean you're
one of the few people you go to school
of Andrew where you you retweet it and
you you know you you deal with it
head-on and you deal with it through
humor I usually just start bragging
about what a big star I am and that
really is very like I've never heard of
you
why do you keep saying you the
volleyball in a bigger part than you
would castaway
well that's probably true yeah it's
truly getting more close-ups but well
y'all had the part the furthest shot
I've ever seen in the film Wow sad right
but I always just tell him you know you
really hurt my feelings I'm gonna have
to go swim in my nice fabulous pool now
right
is it a saltwater pool chlorine it's
netway it's
no it's not it's more expensive but I'm
rich you're literally pouring salt water
on the mood let's keep you for one more
segment so we can get back to more poor
stuff Nick Searcy we'll be right back
we are back mix your seat thanks for
staying I mean I don't even know where
to take it from there but gosh it is
it's it's funny I mean there was a time
where people like you though even if
these people say well you're not a big
enough star Wilson was a bigger star
you're I mean listen ok we're being
honest you're not Tom Hanks right from
castaway but people know you when they
see you and Twitter has changed the
level of accessibility with people like
you there used to be a point where I
feel like if anyone saw you they they
would be so starstruck because you see
anyone in a film you know it's oh oh my
gosh like guys a film star now with
Twitter since they can directly insult
you all day do you feel like that's sort
of taking away some of the the mystique
of Hollywood I'm not sure that's a bad
thing I mean you know it's it's sort of
like Hollywood is always sort of through
the years sort of sold itself as this
like you know look at these royal people
who were movie stars and you know
everybody needs to you know they treat
it treat them as as something other than
human you know and and basically you
know that we're all these people even if
I have more money than you you know it's
I'm still just a person right and Tom
Hanks has more money than me a nice
person and and you know it's like acting
is just a job and it happens to be a job
that if you get very lucky it can pay
you very very well but at the end of the
day it's like you know it's just a job
right I'm not so sure that it's I think
the democratization that has happened
with Twitter is not necessarily such a
bad thing well I think we are all humans
except for agents they're subhuman right
right absolutely that goes even worse Oh
oh my gosh what's always funny is you
know happening with you know William
Morris paradigm and the agents who come
in their sales pitch I don't have you
forgotten this one more SEC well we're
agents but we act very managerially
we function more like managers right so
I don't need a manager
no no you should still have a manager
and give them a cut yeah and the Lord
yeah we're we're gonna answer the phones
for you
okay yeah I mean it's that is true
that's one thing I you know when I went
out in the entertainment industry I
remember when I went out to LA you know
and and I had a few roles right away
clip along there's actually a good good
story we could maybe talk about the
actors union I wasn't allowed to step
foot on set of ABC Family's Greek even
though I had been in the Union in Canada
since I was 12 years old and it's
supposed to be you know reciprocated
with ACTRA is Canadian and sag and they
said well it is but it's like a several
thousand dollar fee I said okay just
take it out of my check you know you'll
get that in the first episode here I
said no no you have to pay it up front
so my brother unfortunately enough was
one of the first YouTube partners he
made like key in a video getting seven
million plays and he lent me the money
and I paid him right back as soon as I
did the role but I think about it that
really is the entertainment industry and
I think this sort of it does stem from
this narcissistic liberal mindset I hate
to politicize it they do eat their young
do you feel like that's a real problem
eat their young and what sense what do
you mean well I mean they just think
they can't I mean there's no one who
comes out of that industry as a general
rule who comes up through the system I
mean you're already successful now and
you're an older gentleman but it just
seems to destroy young people like it's
corrosive to the soul maybe it's just me
but I feel like that's a noticeable
trend yeah I think it's very hard to
start in this business you know as a
child or a young adult and if you get a
lot of success early on you know it's
all based on what you look like at a
certain point in your life and if then
look changes to the point that it's no
longer marketable and you still think
you should be treated the way you were
treated when you were royalty because
you were on a television show it can
really mess you up you know and and and
you know I think it's I think that's
true to some degree in any stage I
didn't really get started in the film
business until I was 31 or something
I've done a lot of plays but I never
- I mean most people at that point are
winding down if they haven't hit their
homerun by that point they're packing
their bags what what what's the story
they're 31 Nick Searcy well actually I
was thinking of packing my bags we had
been in New York my wife and I've been
in New York for a long time and you know
I've done a lot of place but never
gotten a film career started and then
she came up pregnant for some how I
don't know how that happened but we
decided we couldn't have the baby in New
York City so we were we moved back down
to North Carolina I was thinking of
going back to school and maybe getting a
master's degree or something I got a
little agent in North Carolina and since
I've been in New York you know they
thought I was something special so they
sent me out a lot and there were a lot
of movies that were shooting in North
Carolina back then I sort of got a
little part in Days of Thunder a little
part and Prince of tides you know some
other things that came in and then I
wound up reading for a little part in
fried green tomatoes and Jon Avnet the
director of that movie said I want to
read Nick for Frank and I ended up
reading for the main villain and got
that part
eventually in fried green tomatoes and
that sort of gave me enough of a profile
that I could now was a one-hour photo
before or after that after that way oh
yeah okay that would make sense ever
seen anything like I remember Nick was
in that you know it happens yeah that
was that was 2000 I think fried green
tomatoes was 1991 that's kind of when it
all started for Nick Searcy started well
you know it's um it's it's funny you
mention that was me with Montreal I
started when I was 12 but I was fired
hit 14 because my voice changed doing
yeah it's like you just sort of grow out
of something and they like okay we don't
need that anymore which I would think
you know for me it bred a really strong
conservative worldview I mean I was
raised in a Christian household so that
no one no one can say I was I was raised
Christian you have to choose at some
point everyone does but then what
happened was you know being fired at 14
and sink-or-swim and going out in
auditions in the rejection I thought
like well this this isn't fair life
isn't fair and I just I'm just going to
have to keep swinging the bat and be
okay with failing and I thought
they shouldn't be able to take half of
my money once I do make it oh who
literally is a 13 year old I've watched
my Arthur checks and I was amazed that
not everyone in the entertainment
history felt that way going through
those experiences is confusing I don't I
don't see how they think that that's
fair that you know you you struggle to
try to build something you starve you
know your work on job trying to build a
career and then finally when you build
one they start going oh congratulations
I'll have half right yeah yeah but it
seems like there's gonna be more outrage
yeah there definitely should be in dumb
but you know I'm not a huge fan of ously
of unions in general and and sag that
was a real ordeal for me when I switched
over from Canada to the United States
but same thing Montreal had a big film
industry like like North Carolina or
with North Carolina South Carolina he
said South Carolina don't really travel
much they can't really cross pay fines
yeah it's tough to do with those what do
you call those things on the trains that
you have to manually pump on the train
tracks yeah yeah that's how they get
around and what's funny I don't know if
you've ever shot anything Montreal but
it was a huge hotbed for film because
you know you have old port Montreal you
can make it look like London you can
make it look like Paris and then you can
make it look at New York City and then
the union's came in and said oh there's
this big industry we can tax them more
and they tax themselves out of a huge
industry they don't shoot in Montreal
anymore yeah and that's what's happening
in California I mean you know every
movie that's I mean if you're Iron Man
you can shoot wherever you want because
no matter what the tax rules are or the
Union rules it doesn't matter but if
you're a you know budget of 5 million or
less you just almost cannot shoot in
California because of the tax benefits
in the and the conditions in the
right-to-work state it makes your money
go so much farther and so the entire
film businesses right now is in Atlanta
right now and if they if they're not in
Atlanta it's because it land is too full
and they're spilling over into other
areas you know everybody everybody's
fleeing California
yeah do you think there will be a
rebound
effect do you think kind of like with I
see now in my generation with feminism
and the anti-gun crowd and the the
political correctness there's been a
rejection of it there's been a rebound a
little bit do you think that will happen
with the entertainment industry because
it's it's destroying itself in
California one can hope but I think
what's happening in California is that
all the sensible people are leaving it's
like I'm stuck here like with all these
morons you know and like I can't leave
because my wife and daughter love it
here oh really huh yeah and and you know
my daughter kind of this considers it
her home and even though she's grown I'm
not gonna move away from her you know
she's she doesn't live at home but I
don't want to be in a separate state
from my daughter right so how many how
many children do you have I have to have
25 year old and a 15 year old right and
a 15 year old is the boy yeah now yeah
now I mean you don't talk so much about
am I not revealing any private
information my time you I mean he's an
adoptive son right yes yes we adopted
Omar when he was a fifteen months old
okay so Omar so I'm guessing he's not
Scandinavian he's african-american or
black and some would say yeah and you
know he said we adopted him when we
lived in North Carolina gosh that makes
it tough to go with the racist narrative
as a conservative but you know what's
funny and I will say this and and I was
guiding you there because I remember
seeing a tweet to you something like
that saying oh you know yeah why don't
you show us your black son again to
prove you're not racist you know and
liberals say that like oh this is just
yeah that's not you're gonna bring out
your black front of your blood son to
prove you're not racist and just because
they say that it doesn't make it any
less valid of an argument because the
fact is it is a trump card you clearly
aren't racist with me always tweaking
back I go think about how prescient I
was to it to 14 years ago adopted black
child because I knew I would need him as
a tool to fight you filled it out in the
questionnaire and the reason for
adopting child a trump card
oh it's your ace in the hole against the
race card no but it's true and a lot of
conservatives back away like oh well I
don't want to say I'm not racist because
I have a lot of black friends or I don't
want to say I'm not racist because you
know i-i've adopt but the fact is it is
an example of by racism by definition
you wouldn't be close to someone if you
hated them based on race and I member
reading that going I don't remember it
might have been on Twitter you could
maybe correct me I'm everyday going yes
it does it does prove that is not racist
you know it's funny thing about
transracial adoption I mean liberals
really have a big problem with it they
don't want to fit and and and and they
say you know they and the reason they
have a big problem with it the reason
that they have so offended by the fact
that I happen to be proud of my son Omar
is that they themselves can't imagine
doing that they can't imagine adopting a
child of a different race and they're
projecting that onto me and I just laugh
at them and just make fun of them and
throw it right back in their face and
that's why I'm hilarious okay before we
go because that's a very interesting
point why do you think it is that they
can't imagine doing that well I think
for the most part leftists whether they
know it or not are very invested in
dividing us by race or gender or
religion or whatever way they can do to
divide us up into tribes so that they
can control us and Pit one of us against
another I think they're very invested in
that and they don't if they if we really
have racial harmony where there really
was you know the race has got along fine
and didn't resent each other liberals
wouldn't have anything to do they might
they would never be able to get elected
if that were true I could not have said
it perfectly more perfectly myself so I
have to get that grammar correct because
you are yes Nick Searcy you can follow
him on Twitter yes make Searcy and uh
well will you come back as we approach
Gosnell movie its release and give us
some more info on that absolutely you
know as it gets closer and we have more
info
we know who's in it and you know all
that stuff I'd love to come back
absolutely Gosnell movie.com nick thanks
so much for stopping by brother
appreciate it
our pleasure Stephen good to talk to you
if you like this video subscribe by
clicking my face and if you hated it
well join the club and you're gonna hate
this next video right next to me but
doesn't a part of you know what it is